vaccination against covet 19 saves  thousands of lives in the european union  but a new wave is hitting us and we need  to step up vaccination further  the good news is  that we have enough vaccine doses  by the end of this week europe will have  delivered one billion doses to our  member states  and another important news is that you  should take your booster shot  six months after the original  vaccination  boosters give us an even higher level of  protection than the original vaccination  they will prevent many hospitalizations  and death  and finally  we need to convince more people to get  vaccinated  a quarter of eu adults are still not  fully vaccinated  if you are unvaccinated you are more at  risk of having severe covet-19 symptoms  vaccination protects you and the others